I love when my mom has about two drinks
because she really it's the first time I
see her like really like acknowledge
that she's a cute lady you know like
confidence and it's nice to see you know
and and I mean it loves it when I get
drunk she's like she dies
well there was a time where if I wasn't
working on a Friday night I'd have a
beer and we'd play poker and it was so
fun to her that she'd be like having a
beer are you gonna have a beer yes so
she that's cuz she's like what's gonna
do to you mom yeah it's gonna change you
well that's actually a really good
understanding of alcohol is not like
just this beverage you just drink cuz
you're thirsty but it's something that's
gonna make you a different person so
she's kind of acknowledging she's like
mom are you disassociating yet
when Rana was really little in that
would take her to shows I would warn her
about the dangers of drunk women because
you know she'd be like two years old
sort of standing there at the end of the
night and they dangers of drunk women
teetering on their high-heeled shoes so
I told her I go they could fall on you
like you have to stay with that is such
a good metaphor for what they do right I
don't know how that turned into me doing
like drunk mom like I started doing like
impressions of drunk mom she'd always
want to play it she's like do drunk mom
do drunk mom then when she started going
to school I was like oh like one time a
teacher told me they'd go I know
everything that goes on in your house
Raina just babbles I guess so then I was
like what if she finds out about drunk
mom my mom and I play this game where
she's super drunk so then I even though
she told the truth where she pretends to
be drunk because moms are always walking
around doing impressions so then I sat
her down I was like you can't tell just
surprised I have her this long is 11
when did she believe in Santa
well she oh my god so what's happening
with she I thought like this was I think
two years ago I thought that she was
just playing me with the Santa thing so
like as in she was she believes in Santa
and you thought pretending to believe in
Santa to get an extra present you know
so then larious this is like you know I
don't know between Thanksgiving and
Christmas her tooth fell out and I
forgot to put money under her pillow
yeah so I just said to her she goes the
the Tooth Fairy didn't leave money
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
tell you two things right now like I was
just gonna pull the band-aid off and I
was just gonna let it I just thought she
knew already just lost a tooth it is
that's when the band-aid comes off for
most kids I think as their parent
forgets to put money under the and
you're like I'm toothless I know I just
lost two of my favorite people
your first sense of death she well by
the way that the money thing I was
always forgetting and just taking from
her piggy bank anyway so I said the
tooth fairy's not real and I could see
that thing go across her face where she
was like what and then oh that makes
perfect sense you know that kind of like
why didn't I know that sooner and I go
wait did you know that and she goes yeah
but you could tell that she didn't know
and then yes then I had to tell she goes
what's the second thing and I didn't
want to I just said I'm not your real
mom Tom when did you realize there was
no drip but I do remember the tooth
fairy thing came first cuz you know my
mom worked tonight she didn't have time
to think about that so yeah
sometimes I would wake up and I'd be
like there's no and I would I realized
slowly that I had to tell her my tooth
was lost for it to work to work and you
know we were losing teeth left and right
15 teeth under my pillow yeah I I think
I remember how old I was like I had I
had an inkling that he wasn't real but I
just wanted to believe it for my
sister's sake she's a year and a half
younger than me yeah so I was in fifth
grade oh listen it it was already very
like I knew I was a smart kid but like I
didn't want to I didn't want
have that talk with my parents that was
gonna be awkward so I was like keeping
it going and I also he's weird it's
confrontation a little bit like hey look
I know you yes that was it and I didn't
want to have that conversation yet I
would beg might I would ask my dad I
remember one time asking my dad is he
real just tell me it's a girl just be
honest the movies I feel like I was
watching you know when Rana was like you
know maybe four or five I was like is
she not getting that every single movie
is about the parents not believing right
you gotta believe but that it would be
what's proper yes there wouldn't be any
like hey do you believe or don't know no
no no I disagree I think that all those
movies are propaganda to get you to
believe again because it's gonna say
listen adults don't believe but then
like with us broken adults and most of
those aren't broken and those who aren't
like who are good people and like no
this is what my dad went to such
elaborate I remember one time and I was
probably in third grade he was watching
National Geographic and there was like
some expedition in the North Pole like
not even in the North Pole it was just
in a Tundra and there are people I
remember like snowshoeing through and I
remembered my dad was like Nicky this is
come here watch this and I'm like a kit
and he goes they're looking for Santa
this is an expedition to look and I'm
like if I were to watch that for like
more than five minutes I would have
figured out that he was lying and then I
would have known Santa wasn't real done
but I just bought it so he was sold me a
lot of things like there was National
Geographic they were looking for Santa
like scientifically it made sense to me
to believe and my sister the day I found
out Santa wasn't real my sister came
home from third grade and my mom was at
the sewing machine in our living room
and I was on the couch and my sister
just walked in like threw down her
backpack and was like I know Santa isn't
real our teacher told us yes mrs. Wright
is right you're wrong third-grade
teacher couldn't believe that the kids
she was teaching we're teaching did it
no Santa what like is some of the half
the class knew and so she had them who
raised their hands like who believes in
who doesn't believe in Santa all the
kids raise their hands who you or she
snapped at one kid and was like you
believe in Santa she was like I just
remember the quote of that all the
parents called about was well I'm sorry
to burst your bubble just remember burst
your bubble like that was just the
that's how it felt like it was like my
bubble burst because my sister walked in
some threw it out her backpack I know
Santa's not real and my mom was like
okay um all right well then now you not
like just like I was so mad cuz I'm like
that's all it took cuz I begged my dad I
was like is he real and I remember my
dad's foot was shaking wildly like cuz
he was just like I'm about to like I
could tell her right now or I couldn't
like I just he got this nervous foot
thing that I was like I know he's lying
and I I believed for way too long
I was I just and I believed in UFO like
and now I don't believe in anything
weird in UFOs I don't believe in aliens
I don't believe no if I did I would be
scared all of the time so I can't
believe in I can't believe in ghosts I
think this might be real but if I accept
that they are then I will be terrified
anytime I'm alone yeah any like so my
body can't handle the stress that
there's a world where there are guys so
I choose to be there like make yourself
no feel lonely and I'm like I wish this
hotel then we're haunted like be like
there's been times in the room where I
allege it feel lonely enough that I
would like enjoy a haunting yeah my
family believes it's so hard like they
were telling me ghost stories about my
grandma's house this week they're like
they are like both very haunted yeah
yeah there's like a girl died of like
polio and they that's the one that's why
you don't see isn't many any mores that
they got rid of
and uhand if you're Apolo okay so tell
me about what's going on at your
grandma's house now what what's what
recent stories have this story that I
heard is that there's no reason that's
that's why I don't I have trouble
believing it we're going over the ones
that happened over these are these are
old and my brother I saw my older
brother this week and I hadn't seen him
in a while and he was confirming all
these stories that my mom had told me
before but also I remember as a kid
hearing stomping coming from the ceiling
but part of me is like maybe they just
had a guy living up there cuz the or
something wanted by about music yeah
there are things you perceive as a child
with your child brain that you can't
make sense of at the time and so you
project ghosts onto it yeah I don't know
I'm torn like I I had a memory of three
men appearing in my my other grant my
stepdads mom's yeah that's such a trashy
[Laughter]
stepdads mom's boyfriend it was so weird
for me to say my grandma's boyfriend yet
you just feel like I remember three men
appearing in a room and I'm like maybe
you should just like gangbang body have
you ever seen a ghost
no yeah I think some people are more in
tune with that I don't think I'm one of
those people I'm so grateful I'm not one
of those or that I'm not one of those
people but aliens I mean the threat of
being abducted as a child yeah was just
always with me like every time it got
dark just means you were abducted
have you taping they are getting
abducted like every six to eight months
yeah they erase your brain love to be
abducted do you have little marks on
your body that you don't know what
they're no but I leap and be still super
tired wait yes I was always scared of
the men in black and I found out about
the men in black before that movie
because I was obsessed with UFOs and
like all this stuff and when they come
and get you and to keep you quiet about
a photograph you know that's based on
like a real thing yeah my aunt
originally told me the men in black
chased down her brother because he took
the closest picture of a UFO ever taken
in Indiana yeah with her little girl
scout camera it was like in the 70s and
he took a picture and the men in black
showed up at their door to be like
where's the photograph and chased them
down on a highway and they looked inside
the car at one point that was chasing
them and there was like nothing inside
it and there were these so these stories
are like family stories that I I heard
these this kid and I'm like oh my
there's men that will show up and chase
you if you've seen a UFO so I didn't
want to see one because I was like I
don't want this I don't want to hit out
on me right I was terrified that's crazy
aliens are so obsessed with Indiana like
is that there's all kinds of sightings
there yeah they must love basketball
thank you
[Music]
you